foreign
I'm a restorative dentist located in
Southern California and the owner of a
dental educational Channel called smile
influencers one tooth has a broken front
tooth another tooth has a cavity
underneath an old crown and the third
tooth has a broken filling and they all
need to be fixed
this case shows a broken tooth on a
mannequin
here I'm using a thin Diamond bur that I
use to create a 45 degree bevel onto the
tooth surface the white stuff you see
here is Teflon tape that I applied to
the adjacent teeth in order to protect
the adjacent teeth from the chemicals
that I'm about to use the blue stuff
that I'm using is phosphoric acid
etching which essentially prepares the
tooth for bonding I make sure to wash
off the etching thoroughly in order to
decrease the likelihood of
post-operative sensitivity the clear
stuff that I'm applying is a bonding
agent that I apply to the prepare to
surface and a little bit beyond I am
curing the tooth with an LED curing
light which essentially polymerizes any
light cured resin based Composites the
blue putty that you see here is a
hydrophilic VPS impression material it
is a guide that helps us in many cases
here you can see us using composite
resin packed in incremental layers to
replace that missing two structure and
hopefully create a filling that is very
strong
and a lot of these have different colors
that allow us to pick a shade that
closely matches our patients teeth
we also have different composite resins
that have different translucency
properties different opaque properties
and this allows us to create a filling
that looks as natural as possible in
this particular case since it's on a
typodon we're just using one shade to
give you an example of how to build up
that missing two structure
after I use a series of discs that go
from coarse to fine to polish The
Filling to make sure there's no Ledges
and make sure that it's as smooth as
possible
now when patients break their teeth it
can be due to a variety of causes trauma
let's say you get into a fight and
someone punches you falling down onto a
hard surface like concrete anytime you
put a strong force onto your front teeth
you can put it in jeopardy
foreign
this tooth has a crown with an axis hole
in the middle of it and there is a large
cavity that's developing underneath that
hole crowns are very strong and they're
typically bonded onto the tooth and one
of the safest ways to remove a crown is
by using a little bit of Leverage to
take the crown off I use a variety of
large Diamond Burrs in order to clean
the majority of the tooth cavity and at
the very end I use a round carbide
Brewer that runs at a slower speed in
order to get the very last bits of the
cavity
foreign
agent is then used we use a micro brush
to apply the bonding agent onto the
tooth core paste is a composite resin
system that has a high compressive
strength and it replaces a lot of the
lost to structure
and we use an LED curing light to cure
the outermost layer of the core paste
although it will also naturally Harden
over time
here we are fabricating an acrylic
temporary crown we use temporary cement
called temp bond to place our temporary
crown onto the tooth this essentially
maintains the space until our lab
technician finishes fabricating a new
dental crown
typically cavities form from poor oral
hygiene maybe not brushing or flossing
the right way or having a diet that's
high in sugar
this tooth has a broken filling with a
large cavity developing between the
filling and their natural tooth in order
to clean the Decay out I first have to
remove the existing filling and in this
particular case I'm using a diamond Burr
to remove all of the old composite resin
after that's removed I use a round
carbide Burr that's used on a slower
speed to make sure that I remove any
infected Dentin or areas where there is
a cavity present until we have nice
healthy tooth structure
in this particular case I'm using a
bonding agent called clear fill SE Bond
the primer in bond essentially prepare
the tooth surface for the application of
our composite resin filling material in
order for the filling material to
successfully adhere this is called
flowable resin it's less viscous
compared to other resins but it does a
great job at sealing margins and
preventing post-operative sensitivity
packable composite resins are highly
viscous resins that contain a high
volume of filler particles which gives
them a stiff consistency
at the very end we are adjusting the
shape of the filling in order to make
the occlusion of the patient feel as
natural as possible we're hoping that
when our patient moves left and right
front and back that there is no
interference between the patient's
motions and the new filling that's in
place
I always tell my patients that there are
things that you can do to protect your
teeth like brushing and flossing in the
morning and at night avoid dangerous
habits like opening packages with your
teeth because although our teeth are
very strong they can break and we want
to be very careful and conscientious
about what we put in our mouth